Squad fam that's right
squad fam squad fam that's your new name
I'm changing it due to popular votes you
are no longer sisters it's squad fam
it's a gender-neutral term and I think
you guys will appreciate my progressive
thinking on this channel thank you thank
you I know I am a saint I know I am
perfect I know these things already but
don't mind me there are actual issues
out there in the world
squad fam let's begin this video last
week asked you guys asked what fam
I asked squad fam to do fan art to do
fan art of me my face I said you don't
have to draw me okay I said you can draw
whatever you want I will review it for
next week also next week's challenge I
challenge you bros this one's gonna be
difficult
I mean squad fam squad fam squad fam I
challenge you squad fam next week to do
anything you can literally do whatever
the [ __ ] put some in anything that will
get popular enough on this reddit thread
the thing that I link in the description
reddit.com slash are slash peopie
submissions anything anything you can
think of post it there now let's review
you guys fanner pewdiepie minimal Feiner
well let you see my hands here look like
they've merged together
I look like the penguin from Batman you
know when these fingers are all together
thank you I love it it's a dream of mine
squad fam how did you know he protect
but he also respect Wham hey lucky you
guys through on the the new merch that's
very cool I'm glad you guys love it by
the way it makes me really happy
me legs drawn in Tim Burton style that's
cool oh look at my own Edgar so cute
thank you for giving me a hideous green
face as I always have as people know me
by disgusting green face Felix that's me
whoa holy [ __ ] how did this one get so
low in ranking is that real is that an
actual drawing this is one of those fake
ones where they just run it in Photoshop
filter and be like look at this
not that I drew you I am so talented
right please acknowledge my existence
even though I have no talent or anything
to contribute with but this looks
amazing
holy [ __ ] Montana Montana 21 god bless
you
this is the kind of thing I want to
print out and frame in my home and kiss
every night before I go to sleep
god damn that man is attractive thank
you for making my nose a little smaller
as well I appreciate it okay so there's
a higher version available look at that
I'm gonna like that because that was
incredible I can't believe it yeah good
old Donald Duck MRA a good ol dad I love
my favorite Donald Duck cartoon it's
really good I see a lot of people use
this cartoon is some sort of evidence of
like oh look this thing used to be
terrible as well if you've seen the
cartoon it's clearly against Hitler and
all that it's not it's not something
positive it just shows like how bad it
is to live in a tyranny that's the right
word dictatorship dictatorship Jesus
Christ [ __ ] happened very nice I would
rate that 1 1 out of 1 very good
why not commit suicide PewDiePie's
advice reason to not commit suicide 0
Depp's don't want to ruin that Kate
don't joke about suicide nothing funny
about it
nothing pencil ho well so sexy I think I
can pull off that face again
[Music]
damn god damn that's so cool I love it
we just got started and I'm already too
[ __ ] blown away thank you for giving
me hair I appreciate that
Jake Paul 5 million subs on YouTube in
six months never done before
okay bless these new youtubers coming in
out of nowhere oh look how popular I am
PewDiePie is next nah fam nothing I've
been crunching for years [ __ ] bring it
at [ __ ] bring it okay [ __ ] that's cool
I love these colors these are amazing
hell yeah you guys are so talented
God dad oh my god
stop this book has content
goddamn it has cuz I wrote it okay
no ghostwriter [ __ ] goddamn it's so
cool this is making me feel shitty cuz
I'm so bad at drawing a very little hell
yeah
you took my my Instagram post Peter Pan
the dragon skater he skates dragon I
especially appreciate the slippy version
oh nice one
very nice oh this is so fun Jase is
Christ zero this next time I ever need
some art I'm gonna commission you bros
cuz goddamn this is so [ __ ] cool
maybe I'll look good with green beard
maybe I should color it that looks so
[ __ ] cool Rick and Morty except it's
Poots and Jack that's so cute
I know jack will appreciate that one
he's such a big Rick and Morty fan I
love Rick and Morty - of course that's
really nice I really like it what no
stop I'm not worthy of this amazing fan
er
what the [ __ ] a black and white
pointillism are you kidding me these are
old dots Hylian shark incredible I like
how you added the the cow waise pimple I
almost said pillow very nice very sexy
leg hair as well a lot of great details
such as edgar farting it's actually
probably my ax that farts more because
you can literally just squeeze my ax and
she she farts king of the web what was
that
six years ago I'm glad you remember the
[ __ ] is this Jake Paul dating simulator
Jake Chan listen it's not like I like
you or anything
hey hater dabs to tuck [ __ ] and I'll end
you on Twitter the the Jake Paul is the
struck I kind of want to see a youtube
dating simulator like a dream daddy
style you know it'd be kind of funny
very creative I really like it
good job Katie sucky psyche I said your
name perfectly you're welcome that's not
how you say your name that's how you say
it now I seen this one this is an old
classic but goddamn its beauty
it's from until dawn I miss that game
such a [ __ ] good game more games like
that police and I will play actual
playthrough ah this is so cute
I will actually save this one an ironic
Lee it's so good marzia has a beard you
drew the fake one I'm blown away
it's our so to get what which page him
I'm on there like the third page I'm not
joking an old time classic you know why
draw me in in a way where I look about
20 times more attractive than I actually
am when you can draw me like this thank
you so much I really really appreciate
it
oh I said you're mine sleepy so cute
family portrait
it's adorable that's really nice I love
sleepy as well so unhappy always it's
Edgar all along yeah I wish you know if
I could train my dog to do my work for
me that would just be really great more
time for me to just play pub ji would be
better
I love how accurate do you drew my face
this face out of all faces I've done
it's probably the ugliest face I have
ever mastered my hair is way too long I
look at I look completely insane when
I'm passed away hopefully hopefully far
in the future but when I had I you you
always have a beautiful picture right
this is the picture I want to be shown
this is how I want people to remember me
goddamn perfect that's how I want whoa
oh my god this is so good
welcome the newest member of the PI
family please fight the urge to dip this
beautiful specimen in frying oil its
knee Crumpton I want it I want one it's
so cute and even got marcia's for his
creature in the back that's so cool
whoa pewdiepie respects like every
second this is so dope the artistic
thank you for drawing my legs like that
really free this is so good oh my god I
need to write that book someone asked me
yesterday if I will ever make another
book this I just found out
said no but now I want to and that's
definitely the title the truth behind
peopie and team 10 now how did you know
you're not supposed to that's so
creative I thought I was good at
Photoshop I could not do this I'm saving
that [ __ ] for reposting later hell yes
2012-2017 2027 aha nah fam next year
this is going to be 2017 this beard will
flourish from all the rape women
respecting it will flourish like a
flower
I ain't shaving this time I don't care
one of y'all say shave the beard [ __ ]
[ __ ] zero death just like dark cells I
love the style of this it's very cool
love the spit effect as well no no no
there's no way this is real no [ __ ]
way
holy [ __ ] I was going to down vote
because I thought no way this is real
and then I saw your video and now I'm
sorry I ever doubted you wait there's a
video of this what wow I mean I see it
happening in front of me but how Jesus
Christ I don't believe it I still don't
believe it
haha I feel so overwhelmed
I didn't expect I'm so humbled really I
feel so lucky to have you guys I thank
you guys so much a million times right
each and single one of these I'm sorry I
didn't go if I didn't go through all of
them I did as many as I could remember
next time you can do whatever you want
music
memes [ __ ] whatever you want
check out the reddit thank you guys Domo
Domo Domo squad fam squad fam Femmes
fist